what is the e use long-term budget for
the EU to fulfill its commitments stable
and predictable funding is essential the
long term budget sets out the e use
priorities over the coming years
much like the budget of a national
government the EU budget pulls resources
investing in projects that have
widespread benefits
unlike member states the EU cannot run a
deficit the next long-term budget will
run for seven years from January 2021
into the end of 2027 how does this
budget affect my everyday life cu budget
goes to regions and cities to farmers
businesses and young people from
building transport systems to securing
our borders helping victims of natural
disasters and cooperation and research
it improves our lives in many aspects
where does the money come from the EU
has several sources of revenue most of
the funding comes from member state
contributions there's also money from
import duties on products from the rest
of the world coming into our common
market and fines imposed on companies
breaking EU competition rules Parliament
is proposing a simplified revenue system
and new sources of income like a
corporate tax a plastics tax and income
from the EU s carbon trading scheme what
will the budget fund and what are the
parliaments priorities the long-term
budget provides a framework for EU
investment in areas ranging from
environment and agriculture to migration
security and international relations MEP
s want more support for research and
innovation environment and climate
Europe's small and medium sized
businesses and the fight against youth
unemployment Parliament also wants to
maintain funding for farmers fisheries
and poorer regions who decides the size
of the budget and how its negotiated the
Commission made its initial budget
proposal in May 2008 een
this is the basis for negotiations
between the European Parliament and the
council which represent the Member
States the European Parliament which
outlined as priorities in November 2018
will have to give its final approval for
the long term budget to come into force
you